let's get into some social justice stuff
oh boy the very important story from the
daily mail oh yeah scooby-doo's velma
it's a karen oh my popular video game
multiverses hold on there that's fake
news i don't know if that game's popular
removes calling the police
as sleuths special power because it's
racist when she reports lebron james's
space jam character
well alright so lebron james in the
video game and a video went viral
because velma's super power is to call
the police and then the police car takes
you in the back and then like drives you
off a cliff and so people were laughing
at the cops were arresting lebron james
or whatever so here's what they did
because it was racist
overnight i guess it randomly changed i
should say randomly but they changed the
cop car to the mystery machine and i
kind of felt like this is a really good
example of what's happening with defund
the police when when initially you have
the police being called and they arrest
the person when everyone gets angry the
cops are being called they replace it
with a panel van that kidnaps you and
drives you off a cliff so as we're
seeing crime skyrocketing in all of
these cities
after defund the police and abolish the
place and all that stuff i just thought
it was kind of funny but uh this is a
great this is great you know velma's
racist uh how are you guys doing what
did the lebron do to deserve this that's
in the video game that's what i want to
do
oh well like so you know it's a fighting
game so lebron is over here you know
striking a woman how dare he and then
valma calls the cops which is the right
thing you're supposed to do and then
everybody got mad about it so now now
instead of calling the cops she calls
her her goon squad to bring their van
and throw you in the back of it and
drive you off a cliff that's the game so
do they throw lebron in the van yes okay
yeah so like the characters in the game
i don't know if they show the characters
but like tom and jerry are in it and
there's like you know batman and
superman and actually actually i really
want to give props to it because it is
really funny because like it's a bunch
of warner brothers characters
and then in the in the promo for it's
like bugs bunny and but shaggy he has
like a sandwich and they actually made
shaggy do karate and
fly and like power up like goku it's
actually really funny but i i do think
as a video game making your move call
the police is kind of dumb
but the point i wanted to make here is
look in every scooby-doo episode this is
what they do
they they their car breaks down
for some reason and then there's a guy
in a costume dressed up like a ghost or
a zombie or something to scare people
away to lower property values that's
that's like the plot of every scooby-doo
episode and then once they finally
realize it's not really a monster it's
some dude they call the police and the
police take care of it but now you can't
have that
like that's racist it's offensive
we can't allow it so we have to remove
police because of the whims of the
social justice warriors is it racist
just because in that instance it was
against lebron james like if bugs bunny
was thrown in jail
do we have them
it's still racist really that's what
people are saying they're saying that
look look this guy says this
he says i am enjoying velma and
multiverses but mainly a character whose
special move is calling the police on
her enemies definitely don't sit right
with me as a black man oh my goodness
that's it you can't like she's holding
up the picture of a white dude
but it's still wait so a black man wrote
this article no no this this this
comment right here was written by a
black twitter so yeah so speaking of
that comment like for me like
my
question to that
that guy who wrote that tweet is have
you no shame
because the thing is like you know as a
black man
um
i'm not willing to
temporarily play the victim or to make
myself look so weak
and so
fragile
over a game
that i'm willing to in a sense kind of
thrust this kind of social justice
agenda along
i'm not gonna i'm not going to to to
to play k or to to basically put this
image of myself out there as this kind
of victim so as to push this agenda like
i'm just i just have too much pride i
guess but i'm just not willing to do
that but the the the issue for me when
it comes to stuff like this is
you know how how are so-called people of
color like how do they not have any kind
of shame
at all
and
making themselves look so weak
that we need culture to modify itself
like to accommodate us scooby-doo has
been around for what 50 years
i i is that how long scooby-doo's been i
don't
know
and it always ends okay not every single
time but overwhelmingly every episode
that ends with the police coming in and
arresting the guy and then fred's like
let's see who it really was and then
they pull the mask off and it's like
it's john murphy or something like that
but see i'm wondering how much of this
is the media to like find this one tweet
this one guy and then put it out and fan
it you know what i mean it's like it
could easily have been ignored like are
people really upset about this but the
game changed it yeah so
this tweet i think is from like a month
ago wow you know and he makes like a
passive comment that's kind of like haha
isn't it funny and i and and nobody
cares but then the the people who make
the game actually went in and changed it
that's crazy yeah you can't have a
culture that's like you call the police
when there's a problem yeah right luke
a little conflicted on this one
i'll be honest here uh i was debating
how i should introduce this topic here
to this conversation
i mean
there's a lot of ridiculousness to me
this is just a distraction to me this is
this is this is the ethos of a declining
civilization this is absolutely
ridiculous that we're even talking about
this there's a lot of things you could
say about the police there's a lot of
things you could talk about holding
power accountable but this is not it why
is velma fighting anyway yeah you know i
was like of all the characters shaggy i
get
shaggy it's actually really funny seeing
him fight because he's a coward in the
cartoon and so the gag i guess is that
he's like freaking out like what's
happening man then someone knocks his
sandwich out of his hands and then he
just goes insane with rage that's
actually funny i like that like that but
velma like why is she fighting i'd like
to see velma fight lebron james i think
that would be entertaining
well you can it's in the game that's
what the game is
why is lebron james even in it yeah i
guess you know
yeah but you know what's funny i wonder
if lebron realized he'd be selling his
likeness to games like this when he did
the movie they're like oh yeah we might
make a video game based on or something
like yeah okay that's cool and he's
thinking it's gonna be like
sometimes i wonder if lebron knows what
he's doing any of the time yeah yeah
some of the things that he's he said in
public so yeah he's definitely
demonstrated that he's willing to play
the puppet in many uh scenarios so but
for what that's that's the thing like
for what reason are people willing to to
bend the knee is it for food
for money i just think i don't know but
i mean like what does money get you what
do you do with it because you want an
infinity pool or something i gotta tell
you man it's not that great what money
is is a is a huge idol
in the so-called black community i mean
if you look at excuse me if you look at
like a lot of the
the music that's coming out right now
we're glorifying money you know i'm
saying so it's like
in a sense we're kind of imparting to
the youth who are consuming this uh
medium
that these are the things that
prioritize these are the things to
strive for and to
uh to
you know work toward you know i'm saying
it doesn't matter whether or not the
means by which you
uh work you know pursue it are honest or
dishonest
it's just at the end of the day this is
what makes you something this is what
makes you prominent and powerful um
it's unfortunate but you know
it is what it is well i think for like
lebron um
it's just a lack of knowledge like he
doesn't really know um
a lot of history he doesn't really know
what's going on and
i think there's also a lot of guilt put
on certain people that are in his
caliber of wealth you know if you're
black and you're successful and you've
made it
um you're there's a lot of guilt that
you want to like you know look back you
know look at the people and help the
people so well the way to do that is to
yeah to play the play the woke and play
the the victim play the the race card
well the the thing about lebron is like
lebron comes from a household that was
you know lower income he grew up with
just his mother in the home
and i would i would venture to say and i
say this not because i know lebron i say
this because i know a lot of people who
were in similar situations is they have
resolved that because i grew up in such
a distressed situation i'm going to see
to it that my children
don't
in a sense suffer the same things that
i've had to suffer growing up and so i
want to in a sense basically uh
envelop them in this life of of plenty
and privilege and so for lebron like
he's very much about like his status
he's very much about like in a sense uh
leveling up and he wants to kind of
create this lineage and so he's going to
seize every opportunity that comes along
and so the question becomes
to what extent do you apply principles
to what it is you're doing and so i
don't want to i don't want to add to
this you know i mean i mean it's
selling your likeness to a video game
you know who who would have known that
it would have come to this you know what
i mean so i don't want to speculate but
at the same time
um you know
lebron had nothing to do with this it's
just a matter of people like like woke
yet again
coming to
get another like extreme kind of degree
so to speak i think i think it's a part
of
there is an element of woke i guess the
woke
they're chasing after
nothing
it's like
we talk about these algorithms on
youtube where they started making the
incredible hulk fight hitler but hitler
had a woman's body and was doing tai chi
while it's saying a nursery rhyme and
the reason those videos emerged was
because the algorithm was just trying to
figure out what got play and what got
clicks and i feel like that's what
leftist ideology is
that's why it's random it makes no sense
that's why they're like we oppose
fascism and support the fbi raiding our
political opponents like how what you're
they're just saying whatever
algorithmically plays there's no leader
there's no rhyme or reason and this is
one of those things
there's a cop
because it's what scooby-doo does and so
they're like oh i can be i can be mad
about that that that fits in the mold of
the algorithm so you have this
decentralized network of lunatics who
are just
filling the holes of whatever it is
could possibly make you angry and fit
their ideology well there's two
possibilities here one someone is
extremely privileged and has a huge
victim mentality that is being promoted
by big tech social media or someone's
trolling i think there's a big
possibility someone's like i'm just
gonna troll this company and for the
company this this mega corporation that
created this video game to cave that
that that really is the big l here that
really is something that that is worth
talking about because
we could just do absurd stuff on the
internet and they'll respond and they'll
and they'll edit and they'll it react to
us i think that element is also
important to understand here and the
more that corporations cave the more
they're opening themselves up to trolls
and i think there might be a possibility
that this is a troll fantastic point
this is well yeah
exactly that's that's that's the big l
there that's that's the big eye-opening
situation that that is worth talking
about but to justin's point about like
you know and to your point too luke
about how much of this is either
trolling or just the media kind of
assert
you know assisting on a certain
narrative
um it does have ramifications in the
real society you know what i'm saying
and my my concern is that it's kind of
instilling in the youth of of black
people and other so-called people of
color this kind of paranoia and this
kind of entitlement that society owes me
something it needs to modify itself to
accommodate me it needs to walk on
eggshells around me because i'm so
fragile and i'm so
insecure in myself
that if you know
the image of a of a man regardless of
what his color is
beating up a woman
on a video game and that woman calling
the police on that man
which in any other
scenario is the proper thing to do is
considered racist it's just so backwards
and in
in and irritating in my opinion thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm we'll see
you all there
you